hey everybody welcome back to new
rockstars I'm Sam bash I have an awesome
shirt on and once again I'm here to
break down all the references and
uncover some of sneak peeks for the
future of the flash TV show today we'll
be talking about episode 405 girls night
out the crazy misadventures a blaze of
team flash and the boys getting drunk
and vomiting in police stations hooray
here's a spoiler warning for the show
comics etc you know the drill and now
let's get into it I don't know if you
noticed but guys there were a butt ton
of references in this episode to comics
and not just that but to a bunch of TV
shows and movies now usually I loved a
number of these videos classic top 10
countdown but since there were so many
in this episode I'm just gonna rattle
them off on illogically as quickly as I
can and hopefully you guys can't keep up
speed Joe thank you because flash anywho
let's get started now be warned there's
a mystery from last episode that I
believe has been solved during this
episode I'm pretty proud of myself
figuring out not to brag but stay tuned
first up just a fantastic comic book
reference to they'd abuse our news
slimeball Ralph Tiffany aka the
elongated man check out this clip of rau
showing off his powers and STAR Labs at
the very beginning of this episode does
this look familiar to classic comic book
fans because it should so close
recreation we've got so far of the cover
of flash volume 1 number 112 mystery of
the elongated man we got Ralph's classic
nose wiggle in the last episode and now
a fairly close recreation of this cover
makes me a happy boy next don't put down
your DC encyclopedia just yet because we
get a small nod to an extremely popular
Justice League member now unfortunately
doesn't look like this member is going
to be in the upcoming Justice League
film but still he's very important take
a look at the airline name that Caitlin
is looking at blink and you'll miss it
but that is he referenced the Green
Lantern specifically how Jordan yes I
know we've heard and seen Ferris air
many times before on this show and the
other DC CW shows even all the way back
in the premiere episode of the flash
also in case you haven't been keeping up
with arrow Hal Jordan the most famous
Green Lantern appeared on the show it
was a second and it was a jacket and you
didn't see him but hey pretty close but
back to the flash it wasn't clear where
Caitlin was heading but could it have
been Co City the home of Hal Jordan
possibly it's fair is there maybe they
have a hub there who knows let me know
your theories down below next up we get
a pretty awesome nod to another show
that breaks the timestream more times
than Barry and that's saying something
no not let
tomorrow cuz they don't have any rules
over there but dr. who one of my
all-time favorite shows when [ __ ] on
her daughter Joanie are talking about
how excited they are for the new baby
they give a nod to the long-running
sci-fi series Joanie even mentions the
new doctor being a woman Jodie Whittaker
I'm so excited for you Ray no confetti
sci-fi nods don't stop there no no what
does Cisco say right here adorable baby
boy with a walk level job
I mean he's not wrong baby Barry is
super cute but was very so similar to
the Ewoks that he tried to eat humans as
an infant hopefully not
ooh speaking of scary predators notice
the creature that's presiding over the
child wedding of iris and Barry that's
right a dinosaur specifically a t-rex
mmm don't let this one slip by you
because dinosaurs are and specifically
t-rex's are playing a very big role in
the DC TV universe remember one of the
most heartfelt episodes of season 2 the
runaway dinosaur directed by Kevin Smith
shout out this episode's title after a
book that Barry's mom reads him when he
was a kid of the same name one of my
favorite episodes and he could be
playing with us or as a kid as a way to
remember his mother kind of sad for a
less sad reference though most of our
other DC eras have gone toe to toe with
in actual t-rex many times in the past
the atom overrun DC's legends of
tomorrow has faced off against the same
t-rex twice in season two and then when
legends broke time had allowed a flock
of his ancient beasts to invade Los
Angeles in present day as a course can't
get enough dinosaurs on TV shows you
know the rule next up now here's the big
reference the most you school about
during the episode you know what I'm
just gonna play it
do you like the Incredible Hulk that's
it I said that worked too much that's
about that's right folks
Felicity compares Caitlin and her
confusing alter-ego killer frost to the
Incredible Hulk pretty cool these shows
are getting to new levels of meadow
references and not you know meta as in
metahumans just you know inside jokes
just a few weeks ago Oliver Queen MAME
dropped The Dark Knight himself Bruce
Wayne and now a hero from another
competing comic book companies being
referenced oh I'm a happy boy also I get
the feeling that this could be BC in his
hat to Marvel since Thor Ragnarok the
buddy team up movie between Thor and the
Hulk premiered just last week in the
United States now we just need the
Inhumans TV show or a tis the shield
when it comes back to give a little
reference to the Justice League movie
it's coming out in a few weeks and we
can call it even
moving on can I just say that I love
drunk Barry not only is he super
enjoyable to watch he's also rattling
references left and right all the time
throughout the entire episode listen up
phew he didn't mention this one but he
kind of did just play this clip right
here Barry what did you just do I swing
got peanuts room bar
[Music]
or did I this definitely feels like a
reference to one of my all-time favorite
speedsters is a quick stir Oh who's the
quick stir you're asking well he's only
the fastest sponge under the sea there's
this episode of Spongebob Squarepants
where the crew obtains superpowers for
some reason and you get this a Plus joke
wanna see you run to that mountain in
back you wanna see me do it again all I
want from these shows Sponge Bob Easter
eggs Mary also gives us this meta joke
when he's crying over his chicken wings
hey flash why the face you may know what
I'm referring to
cuz we're about to get into meme
territory people so buckle up back in
flash season 2 Barry accidentally
reached over to supergirls
earth during the filming of this
crossover we get this unforgettable
still a berry chilling out in a park
when they're filming which is rightfully
nicknamed sad flash there's no way that
the writers room or the flash you missed
this more memes please more means
so don't let Barry keep crying try those
tears especially after this reference to
the movie that keeps on givin references
what is rose make room for Jess con the
door there was plenty of room for sure
easy catch right but did you know that
one of the stars of Titanic was a star
in the flash for many years that's right
one half of firestorm that has been
around the longest Martin Stein aka
Victor Garber pretty cool we have plenty
of Titanic references over on legends of
tomorrow which is another show that I
highly recommend next
now I teased it before but we're about
to solve a mystery now remember last
episode when Catelyn finds a horseshoe
in front of her apartment then in this
episode you see a horseshoe above the
entrance to ominous bar easy to connect
the dots that Amina is the one that
threatened kaitland and the boy but
here's a question
a horseshoe because I'm Annette also
goes by blacksmith blacksmith maybe make
horseshoes you know kind of rough
possibly maybe but listen to this I'm
kind of a loco alloy alnico is an
acronym for aluminum nickel and cobalt
hence this line I mean run a geological
scan of the city for small-scale
signatures of aluminum nickel and cobalt
and that got me thinking why I only go
hmm why well the most popular alnico
alloy is used in the production of can
you guess
horseshoe magnets what can I'm gonna do
again oh that's right you know tractor
repel metal make different shapes use
them as weapons not to brag grown up
feeling pretty proud about this catch
don't worry I'm still not the brightest
bulb in the tool shed it might be a tool
moving on next up take a listen to where
our minute is
doing her dirty deeds she's headed to
Lawrence Hills that's that's all
industrial out there that steel mills
docks warehouses that's right Lawrence
Hills which is actually a real place in
a flash comics another district in
central city that is also an industrial
center just like in the show she's been
doing a lot of these references this
season and I'm pretty sure hardcore fans
are very happy about this I am then
we're gonna listen to what eminent says
here about her and Caitlin you and I
could have been good gods this is a
pretty fun reference to the Egyptian god
Hama net which translates to the hidden
one which is pretty interesting since
I'm Annette in this world has been
running an underground criminal
organization for three years and team
flash had zero ideas zip nothing formal
connection they also I think this line
here from Ralph is a fun reference to
ominous iron versus flesh you think sure
Ralph probably doesn't know Tom Annette
and this is just a fun nod from the
writers but still makes me happy in the
comics on when it can literally melt her
flesh with metal it's nasty but badass
gotta be honest and lastly notice this
line here from Ralph ya happiest place
on earth
Hey he was the champ of eating fries at
a strip club and now he's got nothing to
show for it what a weird premise for a
TV show but you know what else is
happiest place on earth
D is Neil and which also gets a nod
right here in this episode by Harry his
name your regular in this joint
Disney Disney great mix-up may be on
Harry's earth Ralph Disney as the
elongated man and then Walt Disney made
Walt Disney Pictures and they're very
popular
they have marble comics it's a big
stretch but I'm having fun here and last
but not least here are a few honorable
mentions that I'm gonna rattle off first
up since we didn't talk about her debut
years ago when she came on the show
Cecile Horton is actually a pretty
important character to the flash comics
that keeps ago Barry accidentally
snapped the reverse flashes net and
killed him he even went to trial for it
and who was his attorney BAM
to seal O'Malley middle name Horton
you're welcome second Norwalk aka eye
hole which kind of sounds like a
possible Rick and Morty joke or a GI Joe
nod when they say snake eyes his
character does not exist in the comics
alright let me be clear though Norwalk
exists he's a crime boss who the thinker
works for which I mentioned back in my
town of episode 1 I'm season 4 but
tentacle eye man this is something new
and gross but hey it's definitely scary
and off-putting also got to ask how
useful would that thing be
it's grabbing snacks third the weeper
who i mentioned back during the luck be
a lady break down finally made his
appearance and he's nothing like his
comic book counterpart in the comics the
weeper just weeps when he commits crimes
it's super weird for that to happen but
in this his tears are a love drug I'm
excited to see what that means for the
rest of the season and no gotta look
cool and finally who do you think could
be the person that could breach killer
frost off world I'm gonna throw it to
you guys but I'm thinking this could
possibly be an opening to finally throw
the folded man onto the small screen
he's this man who could fold his body
into the second and then the fourth
dimension which can allow for
teleportation sometimes depending on the
writer of the comic maybe this can allow
him to you know fold between dimensions
and universes who knows I know it's a
stretch elongated man joke thanks so
much but I'm gonna did say this so who
could the other two henchmen be maybe
the folded man also what do you think
the thinker has planned for the weeper
and the other metas that we've met so
far something dastardly of course but
what let me know your theories down
below and that's it for me be sure to
like this video subscribe for more
content and share this with your flash
fan friends alliteration and also make
sure you check out our other breakdowns
here on new rockstars want to know the
messed up truth behind the cars universe
it's frightening
I'm Sam bash you're at Sam bash on
Twitter make sure you send me your
thoughts theories feelings and I'll see
you guys next time